les sapeurs pompiers du service
d'incendié et de secours des yvelines
ont fait l'acquisition de 26 caméras
piétons elles sont déployées dans sept
centres d'incendié et de secours du
département dont la caserne de
versailles ce dispositif expérimental
est une première dans les yvelines
il ya un certain nombre de
de territoire dans les yvelines où des
pompiers sont peut-être parfois
davantage victime de prises à partie
personnelle cette caméra piéton est un
outil de lutte et de prévention contre
les agressions de sapeurs pompiers en
intervention
elles ont augmenté de 2 113 % en dix ans
l'objectif c'est de ramener le calme de
dissuader d'éviter de se faire agresser
en en essayant de faire en sorte que
l'individu qui vous menace ou qui vous
agressent verbalement voir qui vous
agressent physiquement évite de le faire
du fait qu'il va savoir qu'il va être
filmé les images et sons seront
conservées pendant six mois les caméras
piéton d'une autonomie de 12 heures
seront portés par un membre d'équipage
qui pourra opérer au déclenchement sur
sa propre initiative
si maintenant la joie un prix donc par
erreur à puis la caméra se déclenche pas
par contre lorsqu'il a plus de deux fois
c'est pour confirme en fait conclut ans
et sont délicates quand ça prend c'est
très intéressant
ces caméras permettront la collecte de
preuves pour identifier et poursuivre
les auteurs de l'agression
mais aussi améliorer la formation des
agents par les captations pour certains
pompiers est là avant tout un rôle de
dissuasion
c'est quelque chose de rassurant pour
notre sécurité
cette phase d'expérimentation des
caméras piétons durera jusqu'en février